today's topic so this is uh this is a
really interesting topic i really wanted
to cover so
here we go so it's very unfortunate that
i have to make this video
but this is where we are and this is
what has come to
if you guys are unaware there was a
black traveler who had his life taken
away from him
murdered in veteran key of colombia and
i want to talk about
safety in this video but safety
specifically for men
because men and women when they travel
they really have two different
intentions
and that usually leads them to seek
different things
right and for guys who travel you cannot
elect your guard down no matter where
you go
and i have done that in the past and i
want to talk about two things you should
look out for because
if you let your guard down this can
happen to anybody
it can happen to anybody no one is
immune doesn't matter how big and tough
you are
doesn't matter who you know back home
doesn't matter who you know there
you always have to be responsible for
your own safety
this is why i tell y'all i travel a lot
i've been to so many countries all
across the world
been to places and i've had to book
airbnbs and
hostels at spot that are not necessarily
the best and i've traveled a lot you are
not knowing the language and one thing
you need to learn as a man
is that it's very dangerous out there
and it varies on your complexion
and what neighbor your hip i would even
argue that as white people it's also
very dangerous for you in certain areas
and as black folks along racial lines
height size
different things like that the problems
you will face will vary based off how
you dress
how you act where you choose to go so
there's so many variables that you have
to take into consideration
and you have to apply them to yourself
if you're a
big big person
and you go to nightclubs in foreign
countries sometimes people will try to
pick a fight with you
just because you're big or do you think
that you're a threat
oh he gonna come here and steal our
woman no but that's what happened when i
go
down south when i go and latino
countries and stuff like that that's
exactly what you're talking about right
there
it's exactly that you know you got the
alcohol going everything and stuff i
have to watch out i have to watch out
because they gonna think that they're
they're gonna think i'm a threat i'm
gonna steal the woman
and then yeah the thing that you're
saying about picking fights yo oh you
you looked at my woman like but they
have this insecurity already set up from
the jump so
everything you do just success to them
so it's just being mindful of that
because that reality is real
and it's everywhere and for white folks
for example you guys are often easy
targets in certain third world countries
because they already look at you and
look at money and white folks will come
in and will admit
this themselves and so i'm not bringing
up race for no reason it matters where
you go and what you look like
yeah you know all these things matter so
i hope you guys pay attention because
somebody lost their life
because they probably couldn't read a
bunch of signs maybe they could i'm not
going to say for certain but we'll watch
the video and see what we can
traveling abroad and it's crazy because
it's like
you go to travel you go to leave the
matrix
to go somewhere else to experience
something different to experience
something new something better than what
you were accustomed to
back home a new experience new
opportunity new people
write a whole new culture you don't go
and travel
to die but unfortunately that's what
happened to
this man now if you read some of the
reports that came out
a report i read specifically said that
he had purchased the property in bed and
kia
for about close to 700 million pesos
if you do the conversion on that that's
close to 200 000
us dollars so obviously that this is a
brother who worked hard
sacrificed did what he had to do i
believe the report said he's
54 years old i'll put all the
information on the screen uh again this
is no disrespect to him or his family is
just information
and it's just like it burns me up that a
black man can work so hard
and have to end up like this and it's
completely
avoidable guys the thing is if you watch
my video
that i did a couple videos back and i
was talking about being alone and
traveling
you know that is one of the things that
i say will be the downfall for a lot of
men
and that is needing companionship
needing to be
around someone now i'm not associating
this with him but a lot of guys who i
know who travel
they are like this there's a lot of
women in foreign countries who will bait
you to locations into places
so other [ __ ] can rob you whether it's
online dating whether it's at a club
if she approaches you and she's too
forward be super suspicious
super especially if you look and sound
like a gringo
or whatever word they got for foreigners
or tourists
be very careful very careful because
that's how dudes disappear get
robbed and if the robbery goes well
wrong they die
the women are often times how they segue
you out because you're in a foreign
country
you want to have a good time what better
way to have a good time than have some
local poom poon
you go to a culture with better food you
go to a culture with a better
environment
that's cheaper but you're gonna be on
the lookout now because you just
by changing your zip code by changing
your country you just elevated your
income
you may have elevated your income to a
upper income person so now you can't
move the same upper income people in the
states and lower income people in the
states do not move the same
so let me talk about two things that i
think can help a lot of men out
who are going to be traveling no matter
where you go number one environment guys
when you're going to a new country into
a new city look around
when you get off you get off the plane
right you don't get off the plane and
you're going to get your taxi to where
you're going to your airbnb
look around this is why i don't book
places for months in advance unless i've
stayed there for a few weeks
because if you book places for months in
advance you get there and it's uneasy
now you're stuck or you just lost a
couple hundred dollars or how much money
you've paid
look around look at the people or the
people one about their day are they just
you know
going from one place to the up to the
next place they getting in and out or
they staring are they watching
are they watching you as soon as you
turn around and happen to look at them
all they staring at you
one of the things that i noticed
especially in medellin when i went to
madison
was that it seemed to me that a lot of
the people there were
looking at tourists or gringos whatever
you want to call it
especially if you got a camera again now
this also happens a lot of brothers do
this to themselves you come down there
your income's elevated a bit because
your currency is higher much more
powerful than the currency in other
places it doesn't have to be
in colombia but in any kind of country
where the u.s currency is
way higher than the currency that's
there and so now you want to flex
you want to brag because you feel like
oh i'm about to make it rain there was a
video where guys were
on snapchat flexing i don't know how
much money i think like six seven
hundred dollars columbian pesos
and some of them talk to me some of this
talk to me huh talk to me
talk to me ah demon huh
in the next video they had the police in
there because they have been robbed you
can get killed
for very little monetary amounts it
doesn't take a lot
if people see you flashing money if
people think that you look
wealthy or they think that you have a
lot of money wealthy or they think that
you have a lot of money they're going to
target you won't be now
but people watch your patterns yeah you
have to be aware of what you look like
to other
cultures this is a good thing to travel
to other country right
but you have to understand what certain
things about you
represents in other countries i want to
go to haiti i
have to know what tattoos represents in
haiti i want to go to colombia
if you know what i mean so you have to
know what the dreads look and what they
mean to the people out there it's good
to inform yourself
about the cultures about different
things about that you have
i got tattoos i'm a black man i have
dress i have a certain size
i have to know what these things are
perceived in the country that i'm going
to
if it's really much more than just
booking a ticket listen
i was very nervous for the first time of
my life extremely nervous
when i went to russia knowing that i'm a
bigger dude knowing that i'm black
knowing that i got dressed i was
extremely anxious to get there because i
was supposed to get off the plane
and someone was supposed to wait for me
with a sign
and i was supposed to go to the hotel
and then the person was meeting me at
the hotel
i was super anxious don't know what
could have happened there you have to be
aware of these things
now i know people are going to be like
that's victim blaming
i think it's being aware of what's going
on of what's going on around you
and not living in a utopia not living in
a dream
world that these are facts if you want
to go back home
i'm not this is not a disclaimer if you
want to go back home you have to take
care of those things you have to watch
out for that
that's just being smart okay okay i'm
going to say this very clearly if
anybody comes to this video starts
talking about victim blaming
you can see yourself at the door that is
a problem used by
privileged people that is a western term
used by people who don't face danger on
a regular basis
that's what that is because if you
understand
how the world works you understand that
danger exists and danger doesn't care
about your political science major
danger doesn't care about how you lean
politically
danger doesn't care how many social
justice warrior brownie points you have
if you do not take the precautions you
need to survive
you will likely die so i don't have the
time to cuddle you to explain to you
why you're so fragile going to tell
these young men
what they need to hear because what i
prefer is that they get to live a longer
life and meet their potential
okay so i don't care if you want to call
me go make your articles make your blog
posts
i don't do you think i care about making
sure that these guys
and these young women who also watch
make the smart decision when they travel
because women also have some very real
issues that they got to deal with
go tell a woman who doesn't want to
travel by herself
because she's afraid that it doesn't
does happen to her it's not her fault
and if anyone says that it's victim
blame
let me tell you women understand that
there's real dangers for them when they
travel
they don't act like idiots generally
speaking it's why they prefer to travel
in groups
because they understand that the world
is not a safe place them being told to
take those precautions is not victim
blaming
it's basic self-defense it's
self-preservation so
you guys think what you want to think
that's one two
i don't want you guys to get the wrong
impression i'm not saying that if you
travel the world you're inherently going
to get robbed that it's always going to
be dangerous in these countries and
you're always going to have an issue
what i am saying is it just takes one
instance
and if you want to insulate yourself
from that potential danger there's a
couple of small things you can do
that are not that difficult that will
raise the likelihood of you being safe
when you're traveling i've been to very
dangerous countries but if you
understand where you're going
how to move you can feel very safe while
you're there for the most part
but there are basic mistakes that a lot
of people make
that heighten the risks immediately
exponentially
you know and i just want you guys to
know what those things are so that you
guys can enjoy your trip
and then relax if you keep seeing the
same person
at a particular place when you go there
it's a good chance that they're just
there watching people
a lot of these people i have no clue
what they do but i only got a lot of
time on our hands
and i got a lot of time to watch you mr
gringo walking out with your bags
walking out looking fresh
and you think oh i'm so big and so tough
i can't get touched yeah maybe in a fist
fight you're good to go
but what about when he pulls out a gun
and puts it in your face
then how are you gonna have you still
want to be mr big bad bruce lee no
and this is not even just for gringos
this is not a joke
i got shot and this is what i learned
it's been one week
since a bullet was lodged into my back
damon and i decided to go to carnival in
brazil so we took
a 20-day trip to sao paulo first and
then we went to rio my birth city
of course i was born there i almost died
there but i didn't
and i am here to tell the tale of the
time i got
shot in brazil so she has a full video
talk about how she went back home was
spending it partying with her family for
for for then they were just driving home
to their crib like they normally do
and some just dudes pulled up and then
try to steal the car
and then they shot at them and she got
hit in the back a couple times and ended
up in the hospital
and it's one of the most scarring
experiences that she's ever had and so
that's for a local who understands this
so you have to understand certain
environments
very difficult to navigate so just keep
that in mind and that's a struggle even
for a woman
and all this stuff can be avoided so
your environment is big i don't stay in
a place with a bad environment and
especially after living in medieval
mexico
how safe that place was i judge every
place i go based on air that's why when
i got to medellin i was like whoa this
is completely different this is a 180.
i felt none of the luxury and safety
that i had in medita that i fell in
medellin
and i started to notice so much more
different security issues
that happen so much more different
instances of me having to be extremely
cautious for the simplest things
so your environment guys you are you
have a target on your back as a gringo
you have a target on your back
people are plotting they are very hungry
the next thing the most important thing
normally the death of most people is
another person this is why you have
murder and crime dramas
and murder mysteries and all this stuff
right we know what's going on now with
everything that happened
but that's a one-off if you look at a
lot of the reasons for death just in
history
in the totality and the in the annals of
the world's history
the reason for death for most people is
other people jealousy
envy rage hate all of these the seven
daily sins all of these things
are responsible for people killing other
people
so when you go to these new countries
don't be so trustworthy now from what i
read this gentleman met a woman on their
app now it didn't say an
article that the woman set them up
didn't say that right but it said that
they met wanna have
guys i know it's 2021. i really hate to
work this to you
but she does not care about you she
doesn't
she does not care about you she doesn't
know you just
make it make sense how can a person care
about you if they don't even know you
they don't care about you they want to
tell you what you want to hear until
they can extract whatever they want to
extract from you and then they'll be
gone
happens on youtube all the time look at
youtube couples they get what they want
from each other and they're gone
oh you don't think that happens in real
life what can i get from this man oh you
live in the states
money signs the whole time you ain't
living in the hood she don't know that
but she just thinks states
oh money sign she see your instagram oh
oh he flexing oh big bands okay
i'm about to get everything from him
right and now look
she's targeting you she you have a
target on your back oh when you get here
oh no worry poppy i'ma take care of you
all that as soon as i start hearing
poppy i tune out oh pop oh
tuna i'm not your father i tune out i
don't i know the games you're playing
it's so obvious but unfortunately a lot
of guys fall susceptible every day
so you cannot trust these people from
apps even if you meet them
right you might think oh i real good on
vibes i'm really good i'm picking up
fives
you might be going picking up violence
but how about in a different culture how
about in a culture where the women are
actually a little more feminine
you still don't picking up vibes do you
really think a woman
who in the face wouldn't give you the
time of day but you changed your clothes
and now she's all in love with you does
that really seem genuine can i just
appreciate that he's using the
track picture me rolling the
instrumental picture me rolling my 500
beds
i got enough of these [ __ ] there's no
need to be friends i know you want
somebody
but does that really seem genuine it's
not
it's just not guys so unfortunately this
black man is no longer here
and it's just what it is but i hope
other brothers who are traveling other
men who are traveling can take notes
don't be so trusting of people men and
women
but especially women online overseas
because they are looking at you as the
way to feed their family
and unfortunately they happen to
sometimes be a little bit more desperate
and from areas where chaos
and crime is prelim and so the lengths
that they're going to go to to try to
scam you and play you are far higher
so it's just a matter of understanding
these things guys research
google look into it what is the crime
levels what are they like
you know talk to if you happen to have a
local connect ask them a lot of
questions
especially if you don't speak the
language
that is going to be your biggest barrier
between you and people over there
trust me i've had conversations with
people that look me some type of way try
to play me then i spoke to them in the
language and it was like oh [ __ ]
am i [ __ ] with somebody who knows
they [ __ ]
and the prices change so fast
but that's just from understanding
cultural layers to these places
just little [ __ ] trying to scam me the
moment i left the airport
do you understand it starts right away
right away they
don't know they'll try to take your bag
let me tell you and then just leave with
your bag in your luggage
so be mindful that they're bold they
don't care
but if you do a couple of tiny things to
insulate and protect yourself i promise
you i have no issues
i always whenever i go to a country i i
try to emulate the accent but i also
learn not to say hi i i
ask how do you say what's up in your
country
oh i go to cuba i went to cuba when i we
were able to travel back then i go to
cuba and i i tell
how do you say what's up oh hola no
that's not what i asked you bro
i asked you how you say what's up
yeah not hi yeah what's up
you know what i mean you know what i
mean by what's up oh okay
hola and that's only cuban so when
people would approach me and all i tried
to say i'd be like
and they would oh okay and then leave me
alone
and they would leave me alone okay voila
they would leave me alone just because i
had that little edge
are the other people that were saying
hola that's gringo talk
yeah that's tourist stock yeah you know
what i mean
that's a little thing but it goes a long
way it just goes to what you were saying
when you were talking to
you talk to the language you talk the
language with them people and they're
like oh [ __ ]
no yeah not cause oh i can't he might
know
more than i think he knows yup yep
you know couple basic tips jewelry
hidden
all your jewelry phones
be very careful with your phone if you
don't need to have it
get yourself a burner or a dummy phone
that you can use while you travel
a cheap cheap phone next year like i got
an iphone 5 that i travel with
exactly i got multiple phones and
there's a good reason for that another
thing to consider this is
it's just like any signs of opulence
start to reduce it
i know some of y'all want to take all
the money you made and start go balling
in areas
it's not worth it but i think the
biggest thing is do your research
get some resources before you go there
you know when i went to brazil
i had somebody in brazil that i could
speak to that asked him a bunch of
questions
and that we came to a consensus together
as to what we're going to do while we're
down there
where we're going to go and it helped
out a lot if you guys don't do that you
are doing yourselves a big disservice
so do your research if you can't do it
through somebody
do google ask somebody who has traveled
there you can find a lot of research
reddit has got posts and posts there are
blogs
and youtubers who will give you all this
information
give you everything you need so that
when you go down there you can feel safe
so do that when i see people who are
about to get played bro
i can tell they're full of ignorance and
they did not do any of their due
diligence
i'm just going to backpack dude you know
just i'm going to go check a couple of
five elas you know and you know what
people do that and you know what they
end up in videos for beheadings
they end up you know on videos being
taken
there's videos online of travelers who
just i want to go have fun and they
never go back home
yep you know and part of you wants to
feel bad
another part's already like what were
you doing in rural mexico at this
hospital
and you decided to go camping outside do
you know what i mean like
it's just thoughts that i have like that
in my head and i don't say this to mock
the person but at the same time i was
like god damn
it's hard to feel bad you know that's it
right so
you know if you jump into a swamp and
get eaten by alligators is it tragic
sure did i'm not surprised no you know
you win your darwin award so
guys don't win it uh be smart about
these things and travel the world go
enjoy it there's so much to learn so
much richness to consume
but if you want to be able to consume it
right to marinate on it
you also have to protect yourself right
be smart that's it so that's all i want
to say about this topic
appreciate anything else no that's
pretty much it all right well listen
shout out to this youtuber he's trying
to do a really good thing
his name is spk lifestyle he does a lot
of traveling
especially in latin american countries
he talks about what it's like so if you
guys want to learn more you guys can go
check that out there
and the other one i was talking about
was damon and jojo i actually really
liked these when i was learning
portuguese
all right so i'm still practicing here
and there just not as much yeah
you know i got new neighbors or
brazilians oh they're actually
yeah well there's something from the
same they're from the same co they're
from the same place that
my my my master from uh my capoeira
monster is from okay that's dope
so when you introduce yourself where
you're like
[Music]
brazilians love it when we speak even a
bit of portuguese yeah the better part
the
everybody loves when you speak their
languages like when they go when i go
to the the greasers province and i speak
greek with the people like
faris and they lose they're like oh [ __ ]
more fries for you you know what i mean
you know kylie when i go like people but
but they really love it
especially here yeah because it doesn't
seem to be that many
it's not like the haitian community or
the greek community or the italian
community
right so when you start speaking with
them yeah yeah
i don't say oh my gosh
[Applause]
is my accent getting a little bit better
it's getting really bad it's good
it's good yeah it's not as good as your
english speaking portuguese
but yeah it's getting very bad but yeah
it's good i'm learning like how to flow
the words in together you know what i'm
saying shout out to you
okay okay shout out to it's a
it's a song yes it's a very singy song
you have to go down but exactly the
lapitopi
it's like you have to learn you have to
learn those things and
i just put i just trying to emulate
people like yeah like my message when
i'm talking or
the guy that was the um the former now
he's not formal anymore but anyways
uh the way they speak the song you know
trying to get it it's like
when you speak to a beijing you know i
mean they sing too people from barbados
and stuff
try to show them love yeah listen
listen so we we we could go in and talk
about portuguese forever you know
but uh big fans big fans we're gonna
leave it at that but yeah if you guys
enjoyed today's video leave a like
comment subscribe all that good stuff
and yeah that's about it
embankment sausage
[Music]
ah
you